welcome back to the 42nd ever
episode of the iced coffee
hour my name is ben you might guys may
know me from
bid boy crypto the podcast right now has
made
forty four thousand six hundred and
seventy four dollars
also known as almost one bitcoin
wow that was amazing all right that was
the cost
wow we're very impressed that is your q
right now you gotta break this down for
us yeah ben thank you so much for
hitting us up
and for those that aren't aware you see
me holding coffee you showed up with a
whole
bunch of coffees for us really
appreciate this
absolutely you can't come to the iced
coffee hour without bringing the iced
coffee so
this is some of the finest iced coffee
from the venetian wow
from illy coffee there it's italian
coffee i love this
so you're here to educate us on
cryptocurrency and bitcoin
let me ask you this why is it that so
many people comment
you need to get educated when it comes
to crypto that just seems like a crypto
thing you need to educate yourself
i i can explain this very well because i
saw this in my own life so
to give you guys a little background of
how i got into bitcoin and
cryptocurrency
uh so going back to 2012 uh this was
supposed to be i think the
the year that was the the end of the
universe i think right 2012 my calendar
but that was when i got into bitcoin
december 21st yeah it was
yeah actually almost the exact day i
bought bitcoin for the first time
i thought that was hilarious because
then they said they calculated it the
wrong way yeah it's actually gonna be
like as like always right okay
that's right it's always a little bit
further out then so
i bought bitcoin for the first time the
way i got into it is i had started a
business
an event ticket business selling concert
and sports tickets uh basically on
craigslist and so
i had to post ads on craigslist all the
time well i had a software that did that
for me automatically
long story short i ended up having to
pay for that with bitcoin starting in
2012 and so
had no idea what it was to me i had done
online gambling before and
you know especially like back you know
when it was legal in the united states
you know for everybody to do
and you would have all these like little
different wallets and
like currencies like net teller and all
kinds of things you had to sign up for
to pay
to fund your account to me when i saw
bitcoin i was like oh it's just like one
of these things
you know it's just like one of these
little ways that you can pay get around
whatever the law and the regulation is
and i didn't think anything about it
well i spent you know
over ten thousand dollars that year
paying for that
service if i would add up what that
would be worth now if i wouldn't have
paid for the service and just
held it as an investment i mean we're
talking a lot of money over that time
first time i bought bitcoin is 12 bucks
so put that in perspective i had a
little bit of money left in my account
between payments
then in november of 2013 it just that's
when
it rocketed it went way up and i looked
at that count as like a few thousand
dollars and i was like
holy crap man i can't believe this how
can i get rid of it so i met with a guy
in a mcdonald's over the wi-fi and i
sold him that bitcoin for like two or
three thousand dollars i don't remember
what it was now
of course worth much more now today but
that was it that was the end of it for
me i didn't think it was anything
you know to look at as an investment and
the whole point is this
i didn't understand bitcoin i just had
some money in it
uh i was kind of forced to because of
that software but i didn't see the
bigger picture of it
i was putting money into something and i
was investing in something that i was
not
educated on i tried to read up a little
bit about it
but it was just over my head at that
time and we didn't have all the bitcoin
education resources
available then that we have now and so
because of that
i miss what probably would have been the
greatest investment opportunity in my
whole lifetime
because i was not educated and so when i
started my channel in
early 2018 uh it was uh basically
in response to the fact that in 2017 i
would have been a multi-millionaire if i
had held on to what i sold
and what i used to pay for that software
and it just it punched me in the gut
like man
my life could be totally different right
now and so i decided to go the course of
educating people about bitcoin so other
people don't miss that opportunity so
we're you really to be invested in
bitcoin and be in for a
long time for the long haul not just on
the hype cycles
you have to understand the bigger
picture of what blockchain offers what
bitcoin offers and other currencies as
well
how much do you have in bitcoin right
now right now
uh we bitcoin is not our biggest holding
uh we have other holdings that are much
bigger in our portfolio but
uh we have you know in the millions of
dollars of bitcoin yeah in the millions
of dollars
yeah yeah when you say we how many
people are the we
so for years on my channel i did
everything myself i did all the editing
all the thumbnails i'm sure you know how
it is in the beginning
and we just got to a point where we
started making enough money to kind of
expand and right now i've got
over 10 employees that work in the
office and then we also have you know
people that are outsourced as well or
not
outsourced just people that are remote
that do things for us we have people in
australia that work for us
we've got research team that does stuff
for us we have 10 people in the office
so as a we like i have a business
partner now
um a lot of people know him from my show
his name's tj he's like creeping
pictures of me over there
um but tj and i are business partners
and bit boy crypto we've got a big
vision for what we're doing with all
this
not just cryptocurrency related but
other things as well
so the whole business is a youtube
channel that talks about bitcoin and
educates people
that is the that is the bridge to where
we're going
so obviously bitcoin and cryptocurrency
on my channel
are very popular we you know make a lot
of we made a lot of money based on
investments that we've had
over the last years that are finally
starting to flourish and really take off
and they have over this year
along with obviously youtube we do very
well on youtube
uh you know with just the youtube ads
alone and then we've got affiliate links
and things like that so
we understand that crypto is cyclical
and that's probably the number one
takeaway
that your audience should walk away with
is that
crypto goes in four year cycles we've
seen it all throughout the history since
2009
and right now we're on the hype cycle
where things are going up it will go
down again at some point most likely
towards the end of this year
and because of that we're trying to
really blow up the crypto channel get as
big as possible
and then we're going to take a lot of
the money that we make from that and
we're actually investing
in other areas of business we're doing
real estate investments uh you know
definitely something we're getting into
we're under contract with some houses
right now what do you think of all of
these companies right now placing a
small allocation of bitcoin but first we
have a quick word from our sponsor
policy genius insurance companies love
overcharging for their services and
policy genius will help prevent that
from happening to you you
can save over a thousand dollars a year
by reshopping for insurance
and here's exactly how policy genius is
gonna save you money you first answer a
few questions about yourself
and your property and after that policy
genius just takes it from there they
will compare rates from over
30 of the top insurers from progressive
to nationwide to find your lowest quotes
then the policy genius team will look at
all of the ways to maximize your savings
including bundling your home and auto
policies and the best part is if policy
genius finds a better rate than what
you're paying for
now they will switch you over for free
it costs absolutely nothing it's super
fast and it will save you loads of money
on your insurance and that kind of
service has earned policy jesus a
five-star rating with over 1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google it only takes
minutes to reshop for insurance and you
could be saving
so much money and it's completely free
head to policygenius.com right now to
get started that is policygenius.com
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right thank you so much policy
genius and back to the podcast
it's interesting yeah it it's so funny
when you look at the bitcoin cycles
and how they they just seem to be like
self-fulfilling prophecies you know a
lot of people say that's what charting
and technical analysis
is when you look at the historical chart
of bitcoin
you just say like where is this money
going to keep coming from that's going
to keep pushing the price up
i mean i believe eventually bitcoin will
easily get to a million dollars
in the next five to 10 years but i look
and i say like how could it get even
higher than that
we never expected corporations to be
doing that during this cycle we all
looked in 2018 2019
towards the 2020 2021 bull run and we
expected bitcoin to go to six figures
but everybody was like where's the money
coming from but now you're starting to
see
michael saylor of microstrategy he's the
ceo there their entire business plan is
bitcoin now
we've seen what tesla's done tesla made
more money off their bitcoin investment
you know over the last you know month or
whatever it is than they made for the
entire year with their company
and bitcoin is the best asset we've ever
seen in history
i would say obviously real estate they
don't make any more real estate they'll
make more land you know they make more
real estate but not more land
um other than some islands in china i
guess you could say right
uh but with bitcoin it was designed to
be the optimum
asset you know you can compare to gold
or you know other kinds of investments
and it just leaves those in the dust and
because of that you're having these
businesses
these companies that are awakening to
that fact the scarcity and rarity of
bitcoin is
far beyond and far greater than anything
we've ever seen and they're saying
okay that's weird the m1 money supply
has gone
parabolic i don't know if you've seen
that chart did a video on it
oh well there you go that chart is
insane when you look at we call it
helicopter money
and because of that these businesses are
looking at saying what good is our cash
gonna be if we hit hyperinflation
and they're looking for other assets to
hedge in and the beautiful thing is
while the retail investor most of us the
majority of people that are
you know like number wise putting money
in watching our videos
for those people they live and die on
bitcoin cycles when the price is going
up they're excited when it's going down
they're sad
they come in at the top they leave at
the bottom when they should be doing it
the reverse way
but you have these larger companies that
are looking they're saying hmm
where's this going to be in 20 years
just gonna be in 10 to 15 to 20 years
and they're not selling in the middle
you know they're not going to be giving
up that bitcoin that's in their
treasuries
and they're seeing the long-term value
and implications of what
this has and it's actually we're seeing
bitcoin become more of a sure
asset than the dollar you know um and
it's just an interesting you know
paradigm that we're seeing kind of
change right now
that the smartest people in the world
the smartest people in business in
america
are also waking up to that elon musk
michael saylor you know among others and
don't think you know tim cook and apple
are not looking at this don't think
the ceo of alphabet's not looking at
this jeff bezos is not looking at this
they're all seeing what's happening
um the kind of estimate that michael
saylor put out who had a conference
where he met with i think 1400
um different executives from around you
know more than top
fortune 500 companies he says he thinks
by the end of this year you know
half of all corporations will have
bitcoin in their in their uh treasuries
why is there a four year cycle
yeah so this this is where we get into
kind of the nerdy stuff about crypto
that i think is so
interesting i like to say on my channel
like i'm a regular guy
like i'm not super techy i'm not super
nerdy
uh i don't i don't get into a lot of the
things uh that
you know i don't get into bitcoin mining
i just was a guy that saw the
opportunity and got in and was like man
this is amazing and i've learned about
all of it and
the bitcoin cycles are based on bitcoin
mining right so
if people are unaware of what bitcoin
mining is it's basically
you know computers solving complex math
problems and when they solve those math
problems
a portion of a bitcoin is rewarded to
them
uh and so the way that it worked in the
beginning
when the creators the pseudonymous
satoshi nakamoto created bitcoin
it was 50 bitcoin per block that you
received so every time
a block of transactions was sent through
or you know a block was mine
you got 50 bitcoin per block and that
carried for the first 210
000 blocks we talked about a four-year
cycle
technically it's not four years on the
head
it's every two hundred and ten thousand
blocks which works out to about three
months
ten uh three years ten months on average
of course we just round to
to four years and so every two hundred
and ten thousand blocks
that number of rewards that bitcoin
the miners receive gets cut in half
literally in half and these numbers
they always blow me away when i talk
about it first cycle was 50 bitcoin
then it went down to 25 bitcoin 201 you
know 12 to 2016. then it dropped down
to you know 12.5 bitcoin as of may of
2020
may 11th the bitcoin having it's called
that's h-a-l-v-i-n-g because it gets cut
in half
miners are now earning 6.25 bitcoin per
block
okay a very simple way to look at this
uh
you know an overview of it is every four
years
the production of bitcoin gets cut in
half because it's not as much about the
rewards it's about how much bitcoin's
being produced
and so right now there's 900 bitcoin
being produced per day
in four years you know three years now
it'll be
uh you know half of that which is 450
bitcoin per day
on average where really blows my mind is
to think of the compound effect of this
okay
so there's 21 million bitcoin ever going
to be made that's the max supply 21
million
right now in the first 13 years of
bitcoin
that's all right 12 years of bitcoin
right now it's sitting at
um it's sitting at 18.6
million in the circulating supply
meaning after
12 years there's only 2.4
million bitcoin or 2.5 million bitcoin
left to be mined
the compound effect of that having means
all those bitcoin will not be mined
until 21 40. it will be 120 years
before all the bitcoin are mined even
though the vast majority have already
been mined
that just shows the value of the
incoming supply
when they're made the scarcity and
rarity is like nothing we've ever seen
before
in the history of assets and the last
cycle 2136 to 2140
in four years they'll only be one half
of one bitcoin mined
so every time that gets cut in half the
supply shock
that happens to the miners who have to
sell their bitcoin to become
profitable it just leads to a higher
value
per bitcoin and so supply and demand are
built
into the code or built into the
economics of bitcoin itself
and that's why we see this cycle now one
day
i don't think it'll be the next five
years may not be the next eight years
but you know 20 years from now when
bitcoins at you know uh
a hundred trillion dollar market cap
whatever it'll top out at
i think we'll see that volatility really
really really slow down
right now with it only being you know a
little over a trillion dollars or
i mean it might be under a trillion
dollars today it's around that that
number
um you know obviously you see a lot of
volatility but one day for bitcoin to
become
you know what we hope it becomes whether
it's the world reserve currency or
uh an asset that let's say the world
reserve currencies
pegged to one day it could possibly be
uh we will have to see a decrease in
that volatility but for the first 12
years
every four years we've seen the exact
same cycle pretty much with just
we say the four year cycles of bitcoin
they don't repeat
but they always rhyme but what about
technology like what if the computers
get really like smart that's what we
have like
quantum computers solving i heard did
you see that uh the threat on reddit
about quantum computers
but i know what they are they said that
that is going to endanger the entire
financial system because eventually
they're going to create these computers
that are able to hack into anything
in hours that would normally now would
take like 10 000 years
because the progress they're making on
these computers right now is just
like you said parabolic yeah so could
that potentially speed up the process or
be a threat to bitcoin
well it won't speed up the process of
bitcoin mining because that that's based
upon
hash rate uh difficulty basically so the
more people the mind and the faster it
goes that's another one of the people
things about bitcoin
the difficulty adjusts so the difficulty
would just get much much harder it
doesn't matter how fast computers are
they can't mine them any faster
um but when it comes to technology and
quantum computing this is what i'll tell
people
is that is this a concern yeah down the
road it definitely is
right now is it a concern no and so
obviously
when you look 30 years down the road it
could possibly be
but who knows what we might all be
living on mars in 30 years you know we
have no idea about the what ifs
bitcoin can become more secure it would
take
the consensus of more than half of the
miners
which is a you know bitcoin network's so
big that'd be so difficult
but if the life of bitcoin was on the
line i'm sure they could
uh get consensus to increase uh the
encryption
to make it harder quantum computers you
know they have to be stored in
like absolute zero right do you know
that no that's one of the craziest
things to be like stored in
they have to be to work on the on the on
the cellular level they have to get to
they have to be stored in like absolute
zero temperatures it's not feasible
i think there's only 12 or 13 of them in
the world and they're all at like
universities
so this is not something that a hacker
can just go
get and make now we got to get one to
edit the videos
i'm down yeah yeah second channel camera
just underground yeah that's cool it'll
also be really cool when like it grows a
hand and implants you into the matrix
it'll be like nuts you know
one day one day so yeah the quantum
computing is a concern down the road
uh but to me right now like you said
it's more of a concern about the future
of mankind when we're starting to use
all these computers and find it you know
the entire financial system
um i i one of the things i hear a lot of
people say a lot of novice people get
into bitcoin they say something like
well
like what did we get hit by an
electromagnetic magnetic pulse and
you know there's no power how are you
going to get to your bitcoin well
the cool thing is when you can get back
to it it will still be there
but if there's an electromagnetic pulse
that hits the united states and nobody
has power
your bitcoin is not going to be your
concern you certainly won't have access
to your atm
you certainly won't have access to your
money in the bank account so it's
actually
you know that won't be guaranteed to be
there when you get back but because a
blockchain when you get power back like
the bitcoin would actually be there
the point is we would have much larger
concerns if that happened
same thing with quantum computing like
you said the entire financial system
could be turned on its head now
the dangerous thing would be of like
north korea got access to a quantum
computer or
you know at some kind of rogue state
then we might could start having some of
these conversations but
we would probably know that well for
what was happening but first we have to
thank this video sponsor grammarly there
have been
so many times in my life where i've had
trouble writing effectively or
expressing myself clearly
usually when we invite people onto the
podcast it requires me to reach out to
the guest via dm
asking if they would like to come on
this process can be really timely and my
writing needs to be exact in order to be
successful in cases like this
it really helps to have grammarly
premium grammarly is a digital writing
assistant that will review any writing
that you do and tell you how your tone
comes off give you alternative vocab
suggestions
and help with your structure i know not
everyone has to dm people trying to get
them to come onto their podcast but
grammarly premium can be used in plenty
of situations such as checking in on
your family
sending recaps to teams in your
organization or sharing big news with
your friends
i find myself using grammarly premium
more and more just because of how easy
it is plus it's nice to know that
whenever i am sending a message to
someone i know that none of my
intentions can be lost in how they
receive the message evaluate your
writing with 20
off grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
iced coffee that's 20 off grammarly
premium at grammarly g
r a m a r l y dot com slash iced coffee
thank you so much grammarly for
sponsoring this and back to the podcast
so before that what else do you think
would be a threat to bitcoin
like realistically realistically to me
the largest threat to bitcoin
is china and and the reason i don't get
political about stuff but
what i will say on this topic is that
when you look at the bitcoin mining
and you look at the hash rate and that
consensus that we're talking about
the majority of the hash rate is located
in china across mining farms so over 50
of bitcoin's hash rate which is what it
would take to attack
uh bitcoin uh would be over there and so
we know china's communist which means
there isn't technically a such thing as
a private business there
so if the chinese government want to
come in and take over everything you
know
all these mining farms i mean it would
be very difficult
but they could do it but then there
would still have to be an immense amount
of coordination
to make that happen and i'm sure we
would know that was happening well
you know what would they do let's say
they took it over yeah what would what
would they do with that
if you could if you could get um
the majority of the hash rate you can do
what's called a 51
attack that's a hack now i'm not a
programmer
i'm not a coder like you said i'm i'm
just a regular guy like i'm
not super versed on the technological
side of things
uh when it comes to you know how to code
blockchain okay
but my understanding of a 51 attack
we've seen them on other
cryptocurrencies that have smaller
networks because it's easier to do
you would do a double spend you would
basically be able to reverse some of the
transactions on the blockchain and if
you did that
everything starts getting out of control
you know people are losing money
and then the main thing is the network
security is in question and and the
great thing about bitcoin is that
network security
has never been in question it's got the
largest network of decentralized nodes
of any cryptocurrency by far
that's what gives it its true power and
strength over other cryptocurrencies
right now
um so it would basically just be a thing
where the security would be questioned
or transactions could be uh you know
could be hacked and you know people
could lose a lot of money it would be
definitely a bad deal
do i think that's ever going to happen
no i i don't think that could happen
but if you were to ask me my only
concern about the future of bitcoin
uh and and something that could happen
that would be it that you know basically
they would give the majority of the
hashtag do that
what about regulation regulation are you
not worried about that
not at all for bitcoin i mean you can't
regulate open source code
that's all it is bitcoin is open source
code you can't regulate that
the only thing that regulation could
do with bitcoin because here's what you
have to understand michael saylor and
michael
uh of microstrategy said this he's kind
of like our folk hero these days in
cryptocurrency
he was on cnbc the other day and he put
it very beautifully he said
you know bitcoin's not an investment
bitcoin is not a stock it's not a
representation
of something else it's property you own
bitcoin
it's it's an asset itself it's not like
with gold or silver market where you get
like you know
something that says um you know a little
piece of paper that says you own it
you can store it in your own wallet
independent of everywhere else
so for the regulation side of things
it's difficult to attack that
and we've seen it right every time a
country says they're gonna ban bitcoin
there's like panic because the novice
person doesn't understand it's not
possible you cannot ban bitcoin
the thing that they can do is they can
actually
regulate the fiat on and off ramps so
right now we have coinbase and i can
make so many arguments about
why this will never happen but if the
u.s government were to ban
coinbase a company by the way that's
going public uh
you know this year yeah if you if you
were to ban them
and say people can't put fiat money in
there to get bitcoin
that that's where you could start
getting into problems we've seen that in
other countries
where they they restrict the way you can
take money in there was actually
something in england a while back
uh where they had uh banned a certain
bank from being able to issue
coinbase withdrawals and you know funny
enough i actually had my bank account
closed
uh by bb t uh because
uh of a coinbase transaction that they
said it was fraud uh
so it shows like you know we're really
up against this legacy system
and they kind of know what's going on
but the only way to really
regulate bitcoin per se is the fiat on
and off ramps because once people have
it
you know there's nothing you really do
about it you you can't force them to
give you access to it like you can with
other stuff what do you think about the
coinbase ipo
i heard that it was going to be 60
billion dollars as of now yeah wouldn't
be surprised if the next day it's 100.
that's something i want to get in that
so badly pre-ipo yeah
so be careful fingers crossed yeah for
what what should i be i really believe i
i it's
it's expensive but there aren't that
many platforms right now
that do what coinbase is doing and i
think they have the first mover
advantage through the biggest by far
and i use them so i feel like if i use
them all everyone else is doing it
you know everybody you know that's been
my go-to metric on so many things
it's like well if i like it chances are
everyone else does too
yeah so well that's that's how i knew i
was going to come on your show one day
because you showed a screenshot of my
channel use my channel
did i yeah oh yeah come on
come on no there's no oops okay yeah uh
but in all these years
with coinbase i agree uh you know a lot
of people give coinbase a lot of grief
in crypto because you know they make all
kinds of arguments of like it's got high
fees and
stuff you're paying for convenience
first of all and if you want lower fees
there's actually a version called
coinbase pro that you can use i am a
pretty big fan of coinbase i have said
some stuff you know throughout my years
and
on youtube some negative things about
them i haven't agreed with every
decision
uh you know the the ceo brian armstrong
uh we have the same last name so i
always got to tell people like we're not
related in any way
you can tell because he's bald and you
guys you know getting these luscious
locks here okay
uh but the thing about coinbase is it's
a very beginner friendly it's very user
friendly
however when it comes to the ipo you
know and i don't know what cost
you know you could get in that i i don't
you know i don't do a lot of stock
investing that's something
we're going to be talking about more on
my channel in the future is we've got a
lot of money in crypto and we want to be
able to protect it in different ways and
hedge it
um but chamath paula hapatia
i'm sure you're you're familiar with him
he recently had a thread on
twitter that it seems like to him is
what's happening right now is they're
really
overvaluing the coinbase ipo and it's
going to list and that's going to do you
know similar to what facebook did and
dropped dramatically so
my thing is what what we're looking to
do is go ahead and let it ipo
and then wait till it bottoms and then
invest we want to be invested in
coinbase i mean because i agree it is
it's far and away the best platform for
beginners there's far better exchanges
out there in reality
but for beginners you basically can't
mess coinbase up
you can mess up other exchanges you can
accidentally like buy a bunch of the
wrong price of any cryptocurrency and
end up getting like totally wrecked
if you don't know what you're doing the
limit orders and things like that so
what's the best exchange
that is out there yeah so for me
you just got to break it down into
different categories right so
the best for a beginner is coinbase the
best for people in the united states
almost every state has access is
binance.us
kucoin is an exchange that's it's a
little it's a little uh you know it's
had some issues in the past
but it is pretty reputable and we use it
there you don't have to do kyc
so you don't have to worry about where
you live to use it in addition to that
it's got a huge selection of coins it's
got i think the most coins in all of
cryptocurrency
and then of course you got the the
deeper level of cryptocurrency which is
what's that robin hood well no not robin
hood kidding i'm kidding we're not
kidding yeah and i would like to talk
about that in a second though but then
you have the deeper level of the
decentralized exchanges which you know
we have
uniswap uh bitswapdex.io that's a
decentralized exchange that we run
so that's that's a little more on the
crypto djinn level
as we like to say a decentralized
exchange in crypto is where
you are trading crypto with other people
through a platform you're not trading
with the exchange
and you're you you don't ever have to
send your money
to the exchange it stays in your wallet
a third-party wallet the whole time
and everything's done decentralized so
there's nobody in the middle of that
election
how is money made on that for the
website um
well there are like with unit swap for
instance
uh there's a fee there's a very small
fee it's a it's a
very small fraction of a percentage but
it's a volume play so you're getting a
lot of volume on the exchange
and over time it adds up but unit swap
itself which is the biggest
decentralized exchange
on ethereum many ways and it has its own
coin
so basically there's a liquidity process
where users can go and stake liquidity
for different coins
so they're getting pegging them on that
fee that's the pool
in which users are going to come and
trade and they're going to pull from
that liquidity pool
so you can you can make money on both
sides so they're making money off of the
fee but then
you know there's a fee on the liquidity
pools as well so somebody's got to be
there to
put the tokens in for people to come
trade with yeah that makes sense one
thing i want to ask you before i forget
is tether yeah what are your thoughts on
tether but really quick we have a word
from our sponsor skillshare skillshare
offers
thousands of inspiring classes for
creative and curious people they have
topics ranging from illustration design
and photography to video freelancing and
more
recently i was just browsing through the
class catalog and i noticed that
youtuber ali abdull has an editing class
now this was super exciting for me to
hear because i've always respected ali's
video editing skills and i knew he could
provide a bunch of really valuable
insight into how to up your editing game
now of course i recognize that not all
of you are editors but that's fine
because skillshare is made for everyone
there are
loads of other classes to take that
cover a very wide range of topics
skillshare is also incredibly affordable
especially when compared to pricey
in-person classes an annual subscription
is less than 10
a month even if you don't have anything
specific in mind i think it's always a
good thing to be continuously learning
and trying out new things
and there isn't a better place to be
doing all of that than skillshare so i
strongly encourage you to check it out
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
iced coffee where our listeners get a
free trial of premium membership that is
a free trial of skillshare premium
membership at skillshare.com
iced coffee thank you so much skillshare
and back to the podcast
okay so it's funny like can you explain
exactly what tether is
for anybody who doesn't know give a bit
of a background yeah and then we'll talk
about it
it's i find it very interesting okay so
tether is what we call a stable coin
a stable coin is a coin in
cryptocurrency
that is pegged to the value of an asset
okay
so in most cases we're talking about
peg to the us dollar or peg to the euro
uh so you have the two main ones
are tether and usdc which is the
coinbase dollar
and then most exchanges will have their
own version of one or the other you know
and and
they can go on different blockchains as
well like there's a version of tether
on the ethereum blockchain there's
another one on the tron blockchain
there's
a lot of different blockchains that it
goes on to make it where you can trade
within that ecosystem and that that's a
little complicated but
the thing with tether is is they were
under investigation by the state of new
york
the exchange behind tether is actually
bitfinex it's one of the earlier
exchanges
there's a lot of conspiracies you know
kind of surrounding that whole thing but
this is what i'll say there's been a
very popular article
that has gone around for a long time
about how
tether was actually the whole reason for
the last bull runs and the more that
they print of it they print what's
called tether grants
it gives more liquidity to trading
there's a big conspiracy about how
tether was causing all the bull runs and
all the value
and now the state of new york has came
out against them and did a lawsuit well
it was finally
after we were told for years this was
going to be the end of crypto when
you know there's always the end of
crypto when tether finally popped
well let's say new york was like okay
you just can't trade tether here in the
state of new york
uh bitfinex can't be here which they
were already removed
uh and paying 18 and a half million
dollar fine and everything don't you
think that's a red flag though
that they paid an 18.5 million dollar
fine for refusing to get audited
now for though my explanation of this to
add on to what you were saying is that
there's nothing technically stopping
tether the company
the company behind it from saying hey
you know what we're gonna print 10
million extra tether we're just going to
release it out there yeah no one's gonna
know
and then we could buy bitcoin with it
yeah and we're creating this currency
that we
can control and create more of
and just drive up the cost or we could
just eventually
just run away with you know hundreds of
millions of dollars so
their issue was that they've refused an
audit to prove that every one us dollar
you put in
is backed by uh by sorry for every one
tether is backed by one dollar right
and so when they started getting
investigated they changed the verbage on
their website to say well
every every tether is not backed by a
dollar but it's backed by a us dollar or
it's equivalent yeah and then be like
well what does that mean well
it's it's backed by loans and this and
that but they're refusing a third-party
audit a true third-party audit
so to me it seems like a red flag that
new york is like
okay we're not going to be able to prove
any of this you're refusing this but
we're going to ban you here fine you 18
and a half million dollars but uh just
stay out of new york
yeah well the state of new york is a bad
barometer for anything
uh that that's what i'll say uh why
they're of course against cryptocurrency
wall street is there that's their big
cash cow in new york city you know
everything that is
you know traditional finance it's the
traditional finance center of the world
and so because of that they're going to
come out against crypto they don't want
bitcoin to do well
the traditional legacy system when
bitcoin does well you know they start
questioning you hear charlie munger come
out like
you know i'm just going to not you know
dice words here
make such an idiotic statement like
bitcoin is going to go to zero or let's
short it or whatever
bill gates was saying it bill gates
several years ago said i would short
bitcoin if i if i could and then
of course you know i came out an
interview two weeks ago i said well i
wouldn't really think about shorting
bitcoin
like they know what's coming this is the
way all these guys made this
all this money was a traditional system
traditional system is
going to die it's only a matter of time
we've seen it with wall street bets
the way it's constructed it's not fair
the whole entire internet is the
printing press of our gener
of our you know modern civilization
all the information for how these people
have been making money with derivatives
is out there
it's only a matter of time before that
catches up with them and they all know
that and they all see that
right so new york's a bad barometer is
what i'll say they go after everybody
you can't use so many different
exchanges in new york you can use that
in other places however i don't like
tether
i've never liked tether i've i've always
said that the tether story
was way overblown we call it fud you
know for your uncertainty and doubt
uh it's when you take a story you just
pound it over and over again
that gives a narrative that makes people
feel a certain way it's an overblown
story
but yeah it's sketch it was always
sketch do i think the entire bull run
was predicated upon them printing tether
grants
no i think them printing tether grants
was an indication
of of demand coming in that's what we
saw every single time they would print
grants
and then the demand would come in so i
think it's just kind of one of those
catch-22 things it's really hard to
isolate and i think that's what i say
new york found is the whole thing's a
big catch 22.
a lot of people behind uh you know
behind tether
behind the omni block chain which it was
originally created on
behind bitfinex brock pierce you know
some people may know him as a he
actually ran for president recently he
was involved in a lot of it
there's a lot of shell companies a lot
of holding companies a lot of questions
what some people think is this they
think that tether did have the money at
one time
and you know they had i think it was 700
million dollars basically stolen from
them by a company that they said
hey why don't you in costa rica manage
all our money and then they stole all
the money yeah
yeah so so is that what actually
happened stolen right
stole yeah yeah so well disappeared it's
all conspiracy just disappeared right
yeah we don't know
and we don't know but that's why i'm a
big proponent of the coinbase dollar and
and
something people may not know about
cryptocurrency is that you know bitcoins
number one ethereum's number two right
now as of today
card the day that's recording cardano's
number three tether is number four
the trading volume on tether and other
stable coins
is like sixty percent of all trading and
yet they only make up less than five
percent of all coins
people use and the reason why people use
stable coins is to jump back and forth
on trades if bitcoin goes up to 60 000
you move it all over to tether and then
the price drops back down to 40 000 well
hey you just made an extra half bitcoin
if you buy back in at that point
that's the way trading with stable coins
why wouldn't
you just go to cash why couldn't i just
sell it get the cash buy back in
well because you're having to take too
many steps
you know isn't that the same step just
bitcoin cash bitcoin is it a bitcoin
stable coin bitcoin uh it works
differently on some exchanges like on
binance.com
um uh you know don't tell anyone i still
have a legacy account there
um and like you can't do that on other
exchanges on coinbase
they do have the usdc and then they do
have the cash but on other exchanges
they don't
necessarily have that process so you
you could do that um but in general you
know i i think
a lot of fast trading faster trading and
when you're trying to do a lot of swing
trading especially on smaller time
frames you're just trying to do it
faster like why would you do the extra
step
good because yeah it's also a question
of getting the cash back into the asset
some places
you know you have to actually go you
know there's got to be an in-between
step so what do you think would happen
if something happens to tether and they
force
an audit to say and the audit can't come
up with the money
yeah what do you think would be the
result of that in terms of bitcoin
uh that's not going to happen i i i
would argue very strongly
like to answer your question it probably
wouldn't do much
because this story and this narrative
has already been out there for years
and it hasn't done much uh but i think
the state of new york
i mean they're the number one people
that go after
uh you know crypto companies uh and not
just in crypto we we know that they go
uh you know uh against a lot of people
in different knit uh
areas and things like that but i would
say this is the nail in the coffin for
that narrative
i think it's over now i think tether now
is going to be able to run
internationally wherever they allow it
now look maybe european union or
somebody comes out against them as well
but what we're seeing is a distribution
of that huge amount of trading volume
split between
tether and other stable coins primarily
usdc the gemini dollar uh you know some
other exchanges have
binance has their own coin called the
binance dollar we like usdc once again
we like coins why do you like usdc yeah
we like coinbase
that they are front and on the
regulation instead of the back end
everything coinbase does so why people
got really frustrated in 2018
when coinbase came out and said you know
we're not going to list xrp that was the
big rumor at the
peak of the market i remember that yeah
that was a big one back then
and and i look back if you were to ask
me like when was the absolute
peak of the market and when do you think
it literally turned
i point back to i think it was on
january 8th
of 2018 somewhere around that date brian
armstrong ceo of coinbase
comes out and says coinbase has not made
any decisions
on listing any assets that was the exact
peak of xrp it was at three dollars and
some odd cents
went down under two dollars that day
never returned uh
literally has never returned to those
heights since then and so
you know it's also big connect oh big
that's a whole nother story
that's that's a whole nother issue that
was in december when that thing went
south um
i thought bitconnect was the first week
of january and that was as soon as bit
connect
i'm not sure if the the dropping bitcoin
price collapsed bitcoin i i think it was
that and then bitconnect just
caused everything else to yeah yeah well
i think i think bitcoin
or i think bit connect was in the
military somewhere i can't remember that
timeline clearly as i remember the xr
because i was invested in xrp i was
never invested in
uh bit connect so i didn't follow it as
closely other than no like
for two months before it collapsed the
narrative was this is a scam get your
money out i
i made a video five or six months before
then yeah like guys this is a scam
i got so many dislikes that was one of
my most disliked videos i think like 80
percent of people dislike that video
i'm like it's it's it's a scam like how
is it so obvious
no it's not graham this is the only
video of yours i dislike
i like your video it's like so stupid
and then afterwards people
oh my god he's right it's like it's so
obvious but they don't come back and
correct their comments
sorry graham you know they just leave it
there yeah people don't want to hear the
truth about things that are scams and
i tell you i see that every day with
people asking me sending me questions
like
hey this place promises me this returns
and this and you know the thing is why
people are more susceptible to scams and
crypto is because the money is already
so unbelievable
like it's already so unbelievable that
you could have invested a hundred
dollars
in 2010 and taken that same investment
and bought a lamborghini with it in 2017
and yet that's what we saw so
so you like usdc i've noticed block fi
yeah pays like eight percent on that how
are they able to pay so much money
and why shouldn't i take like 500 grand
put it in u.s
uh usdc and just get the interest on it
yeah no reason
no reason uh that's it that's kind of
there's got to be a risk there's got to
be some
catch how are they able to do that well
it's all done through staking
and controlled supply and being able to
remove certain percentages of coins
you know from uh from the supply and
you know staking is very complex but
generally the way that it works is you
know you you stake this here and you
earn
in a different coin so you can take usdc
and you can earn it back
on different coins the issue comes in
when you're earning staking rewards
on an asset that's also going down right
so if you were to take
part of your like let's take celsius so
you know celsius is a is a company that
uh you know we worked with in the past
alex machinski he's buying it he's the
guy who created
a voice over iep uh and celsius
they pay you more with their sell token
right so you stake bitcoin or ethereum
whatever it is
you can take a percentage of it back in
your coin right so you can stake bitcoin
you can earn rewards back in bitcoin
which you're earning eight percent or
whatever the number is on celsius
but you also have to remember in a bear
market those numbers are going down
you know so you're you're making eight
percent on a
depreciating asset what about usdc yeah
wouldn't that be
just equivalent to a dollar so
essentially earning eight percent
on a dollar yeah regardless of what the
market does to be honest with you when
it comes to the usd staking that's
something we're actually investigating
and trying to get more interested in
we've actually not done that before
that's kind of our plan for bear market
is you know the optimum move would be
move over to stable coins
at the very top of the market and then
stake that so that's something we're
investigating right now i have not
actually
done that before but you know i'm not
sure if you're staking on usd and
dc and then you're receiving eight
percent back i would assume it has a lot
to do with you just providing liquidity
do you think that cryptocurrency is an
investment or is it a currency
like store value depends on the coin
it depends on the coin that's a very
broad statement right so with bitcoin we
believe bitcoin is an asset
it's it's a hedgeable asset it's digital
gold it's what it is it's far superior
to gold
um then you have other coins that are
definitely more like currencies
um and then you have others that you
know aren't necessarily
currencies they're what we call utility
tokens
um but uh you know it just depends on on
which way you're looking at it and which
coin that it is
so which coin would be an investment
don't tell jack jack's gonna buy it and
the second he buys it it's going down
it's true
it's been a running joke as soon as he
buys in it's very true
yeah so get ready for this give him one
that's not in my portfolio yeah
so this is this is where we get into
what i consider to be one of the
one of the most difficult things about
being a cryptocurrency youtuber about
talking about this on a daily basis
is that there's really two different
tracks when it comes to crypto
right you have your investment track
and you have your use case track and
sometimes those are going in very
separate things
very separate directions so here's a
good for instance basic attention token
uh the ticker's bat basic attention
token it's by brandon ike he's the same
guy that created mozilla firefox
and it's you know trying to decentralize
ads
right so right now facebook they serve
you an ad
if zuck wants to walk in he wants to say
you know give me jack's file let me see
what this guy's into he can pull it up
and look and see every single data point
they have on you
okay now with basic attention token the
braid browser
they're still serving you ads based on
your preferences
but it's stored decentralized so there's
no one person that can get
access to all your data points to be
able to get information about you it's a
beautiful thing we love basic attention
token
we love the brave browser okay
it's such a great use case it's so
incredible what it can do
and yet the value of the token has just
never seemed to
to go up to match the use case
the investment side of it can be purely
speculative right but you have these
projects that are
actually have working products the braid
browser is
you can make an argument for different
ways to see use case
but there's millions of users of the
braid browser and i would argue it's
crypto's most
used like product so if no one person
gets access to that data
how do marketers get access to that well
the access the data is still there
decentralized like basically like
it's all done by ai i mean that's the
best way to say it it's
it's your the marketers aren't getting
your personal information they're
basically saying
i've got this ad that needs to be shown
to this type of person
and then the brave browser has taken
that and you can choose to opt in you
don't have to opt into the ads program
if you opt into the ads program
it serves you ads and not only is it
serving you ads you're actually getting
paid
a small fraction of a fee in basic
attention token just for watching the
ads
so that would be an investment in
cryptocurrency
what i'm trying to say is every coin in
cryptocurrency really you could probably
look at
as an investment and then also as it
having a use case
so i'm confused because you think you
said that the traditional way of
investing like with wall street and
everything
is doomed or it's it's gonna end yeah so
once that ends
then where can we store our investments
and look for better returns
if cryptocurrency isn't necessarily
investment in investment
but speculative uh currencies can be
seen as well
i think it just gets down to
it's very complex question you know when
you're really looking at the future of
where all this is going
and and we're projecting 10 15 years in
the future
we don't even know what's going to
happen next month i mean we just had the
sec just came out and stopped trading on
certain assets because people are
talking about on reddit
you know like that's pretty unbelievable
i mean that sensor
you would think that we have a free
market but we really don't i mean just
because some people decide hey i want to
invest in this together with other
people
does that necessarily mean that's a bad
thing and yet the government on the
other side when they come in and
restrict it and manipulate it on the
other side
of course we know to make sure that
certain people win and certain people
lose the wrong side's been winning
lately is what it all boils down to
um to me that speaks of a lot of the
problems of the financial censorship
that that we see so really
cryptocurrency like i said earlier is so
much different than anything
else we've seen because you actually own
it it's not a representation of
something
right if you have one ethereum you own
that one ethereum and that's really
where a lot of traditional people get
confused because you're used to having
a stock that's a percentage of ownership
of something
you can't withdraw stock you can't own a
stock right
you can have it in your portfolio but
you can't go to the front door of that
company and say like hey can you give me
my percent of this company right now
whereas with cryptocurrency you
literally can do that you can say hey
i've got five bitcoin on coinbase and
this is the difference between coinbase
and robin hood and paypal
is you can literally go to coinbase and
you can say hey i've got this
hardware wallet a usb cold storage
device
cold storage means it's stored offline
and you can withdraw that bitcoin and
you own it
and i i think we're just kind of moving
to a different place
in investing where you don't necessarily
have to have that representation you can
actually own the asset and that's where
you know
nfts for instance come in um yeah what's
the advantage we'll talk about nfcs in a
second what's the advantage of being
able to pull it off because i pers
as long as it's safe i mean i don't care
if i pull a stock and hold it on like a
little
piece of hardware somewhere just doesn't
make a difference to me
well you know one thing that um
i'll take uh leverage trading for
instance as an example okay i do a lot
of leverage trading on my site or on my
uh personally i also do it a lot on my
channel and it's like when you're when
you're leveraged trading when you're
long in an asset
and you're watching the price of that
asset drop and you go in the red
the idea is you're thinking like wow
there's no way
this price could actually go to this
level
and you know what it does it goes down
the level it's always going to do that
eventually if you keep going
it's always going to drop down to that
level you think it won't go too i know i
know
yeah yeah okay okay i like that i like
the sound of that uh
so um the world's kind of the same way
okay
like eventually there are going to be
bad things that happen economies
collapse
hyperinflation happens seems like we're
kind of
getting to you know on the verge of some
of that stuff with the helicopter money
it can't keep going up forever
it's kind of a fail safe right so you
say like hey i've got these investments
in the stock market well
if the economy collapses and they
freaking have to you know hit the
breaker and you can't get out of those
investments
you're kind of in trouble you know but
with bitcoin and with other
cryptocurrencies like
there you are the fail safe you you have
that currency you own it
and so for me it it's a a truly
hedgeable asset where you're hedging
against
crisis and that's why i tell um
my stepdad for instance he got into
crypto finally
you know after i've been telling him for
for years and years and years about it
and he got into the
uh grayscale trust which are the bitcoin
stocks those are great bridges to get
people from the traditional world over
to our little crypto world
he asked me the same question you know
he said what's the difference in me
investing in stock
which the prices run a little bit
different there's a premium but he said
what's the difference in that
and then owning it and so i explained it
to him you know like the whole reason
why you want to own bitcoin is if there
is some kind of crisis or if there is
some kind of terrible thing that happens
you know you're going to still have
access to that whereas you know there's
no guarantee you could get to a bank
there's no guarantee that you could call
your stock broker and get that sold off
um no guarantee that you know ameritrade
will be functioning or whatever it is so
that's really the difference um you know
it it's more owning assets compared to
paper
to paper trade not paper trading in the
sense of
trading with fake money but like just
trading on derivatives
where you don't own any of that like
yeah it's great to make money on if you
invest in bitcoin on paypal
you'll never be able to withdraw it but
you can make money it's just it's a
different way of looking at things
and and most people that are hardcore
into cryptocurrency we come from kind of
uh
libertarian backgrounds you know like
there's always
cryptocurrency was birthed out of a
libertarian movement pretty much and so
it's is the kind of thing of you want to
have ownership of your own things
you know and so that's kind of like
making money it doesn't make that much
of a difference but
on the larger scale of what could happen
disaster crises
things like that i mean certainly if you
were in venezuela you know you would
have wanted to have bitcoin compared to
what was happening there in their total
economy so obviously
you know where venezuela was at its peak
not compared to where america is at its
peak but i think it understands
nfts what do you think crypto punks
yeah so we've been in nfts for a long
time
and i was i actually just do edit a
video i made on tick tock
uh recently where back in october i was
telling people to get invested in fts
nfts are it stands for non-fungible
token so
just brief description of what that
means
something is fungible if you can replace
anything in the supply right so like
i've got a dollar you have a dollar you
have a dollar
we all take that dollar we throw it in a
pot mix it around we all pull out a
dollar
and it spends the exact same way right
non-fungible tokens or tokens on
blockchain that are
are built on the same blockchain but
they can actually have different
characteristics
so that's what non-funchable means the
best way to look at it they're
collectibles in general now there are
way further advanced use cases of nfts
you can basically take
anything physical and turn it into a
digital representation
within fts that's that's what people
aren't talking about now
um that'll be really big down the road
but we know logan paul
uh you know just released his own nfts
on a cryptocurrency called bondly that
we've talked a lot about on my channel
crypto punks nba top shots some of these
are going for
hundreds of thousands of dollars once
again it kind of gets back to the core
concept of bitcoin which is
rarity and scarcity and you know
the mona lisa is an example i use a lot
like
the mona lisa it sits you know uh
wherever it's
like i said the louvre or whatever uh
you know art museum
uh it's at i don't do art really okay
i'm not an artsy kind of guy okay i
don't like football
uh but it sits there and everybody can
kind of you know
walk around it's in a case you can look
at it that's the mona lisa
but i can actually go print out
something on paper
that you know is that to scale put it in
a similar frame and hey i got my own
mona lisa
but everybody knows it's not the mona
lisa okay with nfts
it's a way to create the scarcity and
rarity of a digital collectible and have
it all in the blockchain
so people can actually see not only not
only who owns it
but the chain of ownership of everybody
who's owned it not by name but by
you know blockchain address and so this
is something a lot of people are seeing
and
i think it's really the changing of
generations too
right we're seeing a much bigger focus
um
on creativity and uniqueness than we've
ever seen before
and then ft's really play into that we
actually have our own nfts
wearable.com is where mark cuban put his
out for a long time
bitboy crypto was the number one seller
on wearable
uh we sold i think 500 to ethan a
weekend's worth
of bitboy cards we've got our own deck
builder game
that's going to be nfts on the wax
blockchain coming out
in a march and april so we're big
believers in this we've got a whole
department of our business
that is focused on nfts we just see it
as is really the future
and kind of one thing i would tell
people is when you see
smart crypto people telling you things
about what's coming
big ideas that are coming it will be big
they're most likely going to be big you
should pay attention because if people
were listening october to what we were
saying
not just us i mean i'm saying we're the
smart people in crypto but other crypto
people as well
were saying like hey this is going to be
the next big thing and a lot of people
miss out on opportunities because they
weren't listening do you think
right now today nfts are in a bubble
they they go in cyclical bubbles they
were in a big bubble over the summer
uh like when we got you know when we
started selling ours we did
really well with it in the summer and
the early fall
and then it kind of you know it kind of
came and went but guess what
pokemon cards go in bubbles uh you know
baseball cards and collectibles michael
jordan's stuff for instance during you
know gary vaynerchuk talks a lot about
the the michael jordan bubble that
happened when the last dance was on
uh you know on espn and things like that
and so
all collectibles go in waves so
you just want to make sure just like
investing in cryptocurrency that you're
getting in at the beginning
not at the end so where are we at right
now in that kind of bubble cycle
i don't know but you know it feels to me
a lot like
the ico whole thing in like 2017 where
everyone was coming out with their own
coin making bank off of it and there's
only so much that that we could do
before it just gets saturated i feel
like that with nfts i started looking
online and started doing some research
and i'm definitely not an expert i
probably know
10 yeah on nfts but it just seems to me
like 99 of the market is just gonna go
to
worthless i do believe that
long term like 10 20 years from now
there are gonna be some really valuable
nfts like
incredibly valuable like the mona lisa
that you said that like you got that
original nft like it's gonna be
priceless at some point
but i think 99 is just gonna go to
nothing
like it like there's nothing stopping me
from going and creating my own
nft and i could be like guys there's
only going to be one of this
yeah bid on it and it would do really
well gosh it would do
yeah it would do well better i i see
where you're coming from and i think
that
all these people with like influence
creating their own
nfts assigning it a perceived value not
backed by any historical data
and then selling them for exorbitant
amounts to people that
maybe aren't fully aware of like that's
what they did with icos
there were so many youtubers coming out
with their own ico
there was one that uh some some car
youtuber came out with back in 2017. i
forget what it was it was like
sugar coin or like something like it was
something so stupid
and yeah it pumped for like a day and
then dropped like 90 percent
and and there were some big people
behind that they i don't think it was
called sugar
i can't remember what it was no it was
it was that that was a big big scam one
two stupid name
that if i heard i'd be like yeah that's
it because it was so bad but they had
like
athletes that were pumping up this coin
it was like god is coming i was gonna
comment and it's just they all sold off
that first day yeah it reminds me
like creating nfts essentially what
they're doing is
selling it off the first day i would i
would make a
very strong distinction uh between icos
and nfts
i would say we're still having icos come
out now
icos are the new icos you know we're
having plenty of tokens launched every
single day
there's a lot of token launching
platforms that are doing like a lot of
sketchy stuff
um but we're also having um
you know a lot of stuff in decentralized
finance defy is the big buzzword i mean
i think decentralized finance
is going to be the number one niche of
cryptocurrency for a long time
they were just still kind of in the
beginning stages of it but everybody
going and launching their own finance
staking yield farming coin
uh that's the new ico i mean we saw it
but
if you can put a dot finance after your
coin
that's what it is i think with nfts
it boils down to audience right so if
graham if you made an nft a graham
uh stefan um you know nft
like of course obviously it would be a
photo of this moment
of you talking to me i mean that's
obviously what it does if you would go
and sell that i mean you would get
beaucoups of money for you make a 101
right
but if you made 20 of those okay and you
sold those those do very well
if you came out and you made another 20
and then another 20 you kept
watering down the value of each one or
each series that you would do i i think
at that point
almost this great because you could have
multiple banksies they're going to be
different
yeah but you could have multiple
originals so there's nothing stopping me
from being like all right guys here's an
nft
of this moment yeah it's gonna be the
only one but then the next podcast
okay we're gonna get an nft on this one
and then maybe depending on like who we
have on maybe some of those
are more like the one with kevin gotta
mention kevin every episode
the one with kevin might be the most
valuable i need to get kevin on my show
yeah i want to meet kevin kevin would do
a live stream with you
woody yeah let's do it kevin i'm
actually i don't want to put words in
his mouth but you just do most likely
well well one thing's for sure when when
i stick my community in the comment
section you know i'll end up probably
uh getting them so many people uh
mentioned you on the podcast like i
can't believe
how did they find out about that um
because we got so many people for a week
straight
yeah mentioning you well that was my
doing
we have a very dedicated follower you
have the army
we have the army and and the reason why
hey army that's right the link button
tell them to hit like
the bit squad the bit squad bid squad do
us a favor
smash that like button you guys know how
to do it says smash the likes way back
here in the room i don't know if you
guys can see yeah we got to turn that on
but but but the reason is
is because they really want more people
to know about cryptocurrency and
um we are the largest cryptocurrency
channel right uh but we're still
like niche we're just now on this
channel as we're hitting 600 000
subscribers
getting to a place where our message is
reaching more than just
the people the hardcore people in our
community and when we see a channel like
yours where you're talking about
investing you mentioned bitcoin before
you know we want to get on and talk
about this message with your audience to
bridge that gap to bring more people in
the message isn't for everybody and if
people don't like it they're certainly
don't have to come check out any
cryptocurrency channels but we believe
with bitcoin that what we have is such a
powerful
censorship-free decentralized message
message that everybody can benefit from
from hearing that i mean
we've got cryptocurrencies the first
time in history we can have you know
rules without rulers governance without
governors everything can be you know
automated
and we think that that's something
really great that can prevent a lot of
the big problems we have in the world so
our people are very passionate
about wanting to see people get that
message and that's what all boils down
to
do you worry that you can influence the
market based on what you talk about
yeah for sure so how do you balance that
what can i do
i mean it's it it's like when we talk
about coins sometimes that are in the
top
10 to 20 billions of dollars market cap
or hundreds of millions of dollars of
market cap
we see what happens is we bring
awareness and people go buy things it's
awareness of the coins
it's a catch-22 it's like i'm a
cryptocurrency youtuber my not supposed
to talk about crypto
because some people might take what we
say and go make actions upon it
it is one of these things that i really
wore with because you know one of the
reasons why people like our channel is
because i'm real and i'm authentic
and transparent about everything we do
and you know
when they see that and they see what
we're talking about
they want to be passionate about it we
weren't planning to come out here to las
vegas
and like do it do a meet up or anything
but all we mentioned is we're coming
here and like all these people want to
come meet me we talked to a lot of
people last night
going to have a meet up you know tonight
and meet more people and that's cool i
want to do that i want to talk to people
but that influence is like like we see
with elon musk like elon musk is being
real about stuff
you know the sec wants to talk about him
about dogecoin tweets which
the only way they could kind of tie it
together is if they said that would
affect bitcoin which tesla's invested in
whatever
um that's a stretch but i mean that's
only
there's no other way they can go after
him and they said there's supposedly a
sec probe on him for saying it
it's going to have to come back to his
role at tesla i mean it can't be because
he talked about dogecoin
but like what do you want the guy to say
when he said uh you know the price of
bitcoin
and ethereum is a little overvalued we
saw the market reacted the other way
it's like what's he supposed to do just
not ever mention
open source code like not ever mention
cryptocurrency and we're just at a weird
place in society
where social media really is such a town
hall
and people have such big platforms like
we've never seen before
and yes it is money and i know you know
for me personally i i don't have a
finance background
you know like it's kind of interesting
to me the way my life is developed that
this is what i talk about all the time
because that's not what my background is
in i'm a regular guy that got into
crypto by accident
saw the huge opportunity recognized it
that's all it boils down to
right and that's why we have a platform
but we're living in a place
where anybody can say anything about
makeup you know like hey if kim
kardashian does
does a post about makeup you know we're
gonna see that those makeup sales go out
of the roof but then when it comes to
money it's different and it's
it it's a weird thing to say like let's
take this entire niche of the world
and open platforms where people can say
whatever they want to say
and just say like oh this one thing is
completely off limits you can't talk
about money on social media because
someone out there may make a decision
about it but that's the entire way that
everything else is set up i'm worried i
think at some point they're going to
crack down on that
and that's been one of my biggest
reservations for never talking about
individual stocks
yeah i've started opening up about like
oh i kind of like a few of these stocks
but i'm so afraid that if i say like
guys
i really love this car but
but if something happens to that because
i'm invested in fisker
and then it keeps going up higher and
then something happens
somebody loses money or let's say it
goes up to a price i'm like
wow i didn't expect it to go up to this
price let me sell
yeah and then i sell it and then the the
sec looks at that says well you
mentioned it here and it hit your price
target and you sold it here
and now you i i think it's something
brand new
that is going to regulate at some point
because i think there are so many people
out there who could just who have these
platforms you could just
i'm buying the stock and it's going to
5x
in 24 hours yeah so i think eventually
they got to find a way to
it's got to be a middle ground there i
feel like it's probably going to be a
disclosure
sort of something like i'm invested in
it here's how much i have something like
that i don't know
well i mean amounts amounts are
something very interesting i mean i
think if
if they were to do that we would
certainly certainly comply with that
we've we have never talked about
anything on my channel
that i was invested in or that we
uh you know that was sponsored without
disclosing from the very beginning my
channel
when nobody was watching the first time
i ever got a sponsored video
you know like we would always say it was
sponsored um and whenever we talk about
projects especially something like i get
invited to private sales or pre-sales
talked about some on the channel the
other day i mentioned like hey i'm
invested in this
we try to we mine our piece of cues and
i think that's what it boils down to if
you look at the sec
and you look at the history in
cryptocurrency i can't speak about the
stock world obviously
that's a regulated environment
cryptocurrency is not regulated at all
but when you look at the history of the
sec in digital assets and who they've
gone after
it always involves dishonesty it
involves dishonesty it involves
manipulation intentionally withholding
stuff that you're invested in
um and just like with tether you know
like some some shady stuff going on i
think
as long as you're trying to do your best
they're not going to come after you now
fair point and there may be some
regulation that you do have to comply
with down the road
they came out and said like if you were
to cover like actual icos
you would have to you know talk about
how much uh you know you were paid for
it
we don't really do icos per se on my
channel so that's not been something
we've done
when they came out with that regulation
a lot of people in crypto complied
like look people in cryptocurrency they
want to comply
with whatever we're we're given at least
in the uh you know
cryptocurrency space when it comes to
influencing
i know basically all the other crypto
youtubers um i don't know a lot of the
ones
i don't i don't know a lot of the ones
who are um
let's say like they had a large channel
and then all of a sudden they just move
over and talk about bitcoin one day or
something like that
um that's you cram i'm talking about you
i'm sorry this was distracting yeah it's
okay
uh so yeah so i i know there's a lot of
other like sheldon evans for instance
the guy that talks about cryptocurrency
he randomly just started talking about
it i know andre has done done the same
thing i know when he started talking
about it
but for those of us that are in the
hardcore crypto community and like
that's all we've done is crypto
for years now i know all those other
people and we all want to comply
nobody wants to get in trouble we're not
trying to
you know always make this little joke
you know or it's not a joke but always
make the reference to uh
at first we thought it was batman but
then we figured out it was uncle ben
from spider-man you know
with great power comes great
responsibility right and we always take
that so seriously we try to think of the
responsibility of our actions
and the responsibility of the things we
talk about but it is a fine line and we
can't control
everything like if we cover a project
for instance
and you know people go out and buy it
and then
someone else somewhere who's been
sitting on a bunch of it
like they sell it when people are going
up and it dumps the market like
we can't control that you know what i'm
saying that's frustrating to me
and whenever we've seen that happen
those are times where we kind of go back
to the drawing board and say like
how can we even find this middle ground
even more you know we know
i mean we're not idiots we know what
happens when we bring awareness to
projects but like i always say like am i
just not supposed to talk about crypto
or
or good projects we find as a crypto
influencer because
people might make decisions we can't
control what those other people do
we can only control what we do and try
to harness that power to the best of our
ability
yeah i think we should go into some some
rapid fire
maybe go for it all right yeah uh what
are the three cryptocurrencies you're
most excited about
well i would just give i mean the three
that we are the most invested in
number one ethereum number two cardano
number three bitcoin
why cardano too many people have been
reaching out like graham
just just a tip just a tip by cardano
yeah like and and so many people have
said
just like i can't tell you much more but
everybody has been doing
why what can't they tell me much more of
it's just these very cryptic messages
they don't know
that by cardona they buy it grant trust
me on this one
i like your i'm trying to help you out
man just buy card
what what is it yeah why well it's it's
beared out to be true i mean basically
charles hoskinson the creator of cardano
he's also co-founder of ethereum
um he came out with a tweet uh at the
beginning of this month and said some
little birdies are telling me that you
know cardona is going to have a good
month all the stuff on the chart was
looking good for it
now he implied that there's a large
liquidity event that probably means an
exchange listing or maybe a
like a grayscale trust type listing for
the stock market for cardano or ada is
the token is or the ticker
and you know we teased that we had it's
almost the end of february we haven't
gotten it
but we've seen the prices go go way up
we actually took
we actually took a half a million
dollars that we made uh leveraged
trading
on not we we don't trade live because we
don't want people to take it as
investment advice
um but but they saw all the trades in
our account
um in in a few weeks we traded up from
like you know point
i think it was uh two bitcoin we traded
up to like
you know 12 or 13 bitcoin then we took
10 bitcoin
we publicly stated we were buying 500
000 for the cardano
and that was when the price was at i
think about 70 cents
and so it's doing pretty good that's 2x
for us since then what is that now
it as of right now i think it's a dollar
38 it was the last time we
have done it man i know so that was it
80 cents yeah
is it 80 cents a dollar 40 right now
do you think it's still good time to buy
so
this is this is a great question because
not for you man
jack do you watch my channel no you need
to start okay because i
i i feel like i'm your kind of guy yeah
okay i'm gonna tell you when you need to
get in what you need to get into
um it's going to ruin everything man
you're going to lose so much money of
knowing
i was going to buy it oh god that was
going to be my hail mary that was my
channel
because i didn't buy it yeah i didn't
buy it because i had to get
well i had to get like binance or
something like that us yeah right
finance i got that yeah but then like i
have to like verify my identity and all
this stuff and i didn't have my wallet
beside me
yeah but you yeah but you could have
castle
but you could have all you had to do and
that is a frustrating thing
cryptocurrency is you don't have access
to every account
or there's no exchange that has all the
coins on it there's it doesn't exist
um but you could have bought bitcoin on
coinbase and you could have sent that
over to your binance.us account
and you could have traded over to
cardona with that not had to put
fresh us dollars in it it's just like
it's so complicated
but that's the opportunity that's the cc
that's the thing that's the early
adopter
aspect of this this is how people know
that even as crazy as things are
we're still early i mean cnn had a poll
that said would you buy bitcoin
80 of people or 86 percent of people
said no
that's how early people still are in
this there's still great opportunity
there will be a bear market coming
so so don't don't be so high in the sky
in utopia and you think it goes up
forever
but the reality is those complications
are where the opportunity lies
because it is so difficult so so if you
could divide up
your net worth into into different like
slices of a pie
where are your allocations oh my gosh
that's so hard to say
uh we don't even know what yeah there's
no way i know
if you were to ask me what my net worth
is i cannot tell you i mean
yeah what percent is crypto what
percentage
okay and then what actually i mean not
counting houses we're buying and stuff i
mean it's probably more like
like 90 percent what are your three
biggest holdings in crypto my three
biggest holdings are uh chain-link
cardona
uh uh ethereum's number one card is
number two and bitcoins number three
outside of that um we like the graph
it's on coinbase ave
chain link uh synthetics those are ones
we're also heavily investing why is
ethereum
your number one yeah why that i'm an
f-head
you know we have to
if you knew my story that's kind of
funny but anyway yeah the
the the thing is though is that ethereum
is the first mover in what we call a
smart contract
uh uh space this is the thing that will
truly allow
for a new decentralized internet we need
a
whole new layer to the internet um you
know just like we've got the mobile
layer
we're going to need a whole
decentralized layer prevent stuff like
you know um censorship we hate
censorship on on my channel
i mean just personally i hate censorship
like are there certain things that don't
need to be said
obviously there's things that don't need
to be seen on the internet um but
every major problem i believe that we
have on the internet today
can be solved in my opinion through
blockchain and ethereum is the channel
to get us there
ethereum is is having some problems
right now with what we call scalability
to do ethereum transactions there's gas
fees and those are
so high right now they're out of control
it makes it very difficult for the
smaller trader to come in
there are some things people may have
heard of called uh
i won't leave ones kind of complicated
but it's going to be to produ
reduce the gas fees but when it comes to
eth 2.0 this is the new upgrade to
ethereum
that is currently in process it won't be
completed some people think until 2023
it will solve some of the problems all
the problems notwithstanding we believe
that ethereum still
will be a huge player in the entire
decentralized internet
and so for us it's something that we're
big on and and we won't
we have a certain amount that we
absolutely will not say now what's ethe
2.0 is that
a different coin or is that just like
like you update ethereum like you would
like
an app on the phone the bitcoin like
bitcoin cash
ethereum ethereum 2.0 no no no it's
going to be the same thing
it will be a fork similar to the bitcoin
cash for but it's not going to create
a a new separate coin so most likely
we're actually gonna be doing a video on
this on the on
the the token swap we think it'll pro
like i haven't looked into it per se
i'm sure it will be automated you won't
even really know um
we have a lot of token swaps that go on
in crypto when
places do what's called launching their
main net that's where they go from being
on another blockchain to their own
blockchain and you do token swaps
usually how i handle those is i'll just
send the token
into an exchange and then immediately
withdraw it and they'll usually send you
the new one back
but they're they're with ethereum 2.0 i
haven't looked into it enough to be able
to tell you the exact process
but ethereum is so mainstream
obviously not nearly mainstream like
bitcoin yet it's getting there
i've always said i think by the end of
the cycle ethereum will be a household
name
um but there's so many newer investors
that you know ethereum is smart enough
i'm i'm sure to make it where it's an
automated process where people don't
actually
have to actually do anything to get
their e2.0 token so they'll just kind of
be you know automatically in their
wallet
so you said you don't know your net
worth is but 90
of your net worth is in crypto so
couldn't you just add up the
all of your account values yeah i mean i
can we we
need a number yeah
eight figures definitely so somewhere
between 10 and 20. so you have
over 10 million dollars in crypto yeah
yeah yeah
all right so what was your net worth
this time last year and then what is it
this year
last year was it was uh not seven
figures
so uh you probably loved six figures
yeah yeah well congratulations yeah
thank you
so many figures is that is that through
like a through a team
or is like the company well i do have a
partner like i said tj tj is my business
partner and so
we have percentages for ourselves but we
we don't look at it
uh we're not weird about money you know
like we look at it kind of like it's the
whole pie for the business
our goal if you want something crazy
like our goal of our business
is to buy the atlanta falcons that's the
goal we want to eventually make enough
money to to buy those options
i mean we assume by the time we would do
it probably three to five billion
dollars we're looking to you know 10
billion
oh come on you got billion well i mean
this bull runs not over so you know
and if the the advice i give to people
is understand the bitcoin cycles
and try to try to take the top of the
of the market move over stable coins
like i said
let the bear market hit and then buy
back in at the bottom
and now you can you know do what we've
done and gone
go from six figures net worth to eight
figures net worth in just a year
so can we clickbait this video the man
who has 20 million dollars in bitcoin or
something
is that fair enough you got to say decca
millionaire deca
that'll be that very widely it is term
yeah but it sounds good
sounds good it sounds good in a uh in a
title trust me when you see it you're
gonna be like yeah
well i would see that i'm like this got
to be a big number because i have no
idea
a millionaire 10 10 or more it's still
the deck a millionaire sure it's like a
quintillionaire millionaire
multi-millionaire deca millionaire
yeah sure yeah yeah uh where do you keep
it all though
well we have we have it spread out so
that's why it's really hard for me to
actually tell you how much money we have
because
when i literally tell you i don't know i
literally don't know we have
you know money over the last year that
we've had staying in wallets and sitting
in certain accounts i even forgot that i
had
the other day like we just found sixty
thousand dollars like literally had no
idea it was there
we found sixty thousand dollars and i
was like oh tj look at this he's like
that's pretty cool like under the couch
cushion
it's hilarious just a little card oh
yeah so we had invested into a a private
sale
yeah we had invested into a private sale
a while back
and uh you know it had just totally
forgotten about it and then i went and
checked the wallet and i was like why is
this not in here
and i started doing some research on how
i had to withdraw the tokens and we went
to
i'd never seen this website before i was
like oh this is a website where my
tokens are supposed to be and i clicked
on it
and i was doing the math i saw the
tokens i like went to coin market cap i
looked at the price of the token i was
like
holy crap that's 60 thousand dollars so
that actually happens
about once every few weeks we find you
know crazy in six weeks
oh yeah well but probably more than that
but yeah yeah like we
we find right about every two weeks we
find money we didn't know we had so
isn't that
bad yeah it's very bad it's great it's a
great grand grandson
that we should be more organized about
yeah where well that's why i brought tj
on because i'm not
like yeah it sounds like some major
cracks in the
business it does it does money going
unaccounted for
there is money and i know that probably
drives you crazy for me it's not that
worrisome because there's no better
feeling to me than going and finding a
jacket in your closet has 20 bucks in it
that's
true i actually so when i was younger i
would hide
money and purposely lose it and forget
about it so i could find it
at some point later in the in my life
and i would be like that's terrible
yeah where's your closet at where's my
i want to ask this uh the irs
yeah if you're buying and selling yeah
isn't isn't a big chunk of your money
taken away
doesn't that really negate the whole
like trying to time the market
and well how do you how do you handle
taxes
we make enough money we consider an
opportunity cost just cost of doing
business we don't mind paying fees
well i i don't look at the small
minutiae thing we've had such a home run
taxes could be
it's not small well we're also we also
have a corporate structure so i mean all
of our
all of our income is business income
we've got you know sitting at the 21
tax bracket yeah okay i have a cpa that
handles that stuff i don't look at it
to be honest with you so we have a law
firm that we use uh gordon law out of
chicago and
like the life-changing money that we've
made over the last
you know a few couple of years has been
you know it's just a cost i mean it's
just cost of doing business for us
and i don't get bogged down in tax stuff
like other people we pay our taxes
we do everything transparent a lot of
people in cryptocurrency have this
mindset
like we want to hide our taxes and we
want to we don't want to pay our gains
and stuff like that
we pay all of our taxes we're very
upfront i encourage people
we use i actually use a site called
zenledger.com that's the site that i
used in order
to you know kind of get things going
with taxes originally
and then once this year things got much
more complicated we added a law firm on
top of that a cpa
to help us uh with all that stuff so so
that's what i do i just try not to worry
about it i just know the money's going
to take care of itself
the place we're going to what we're
doing is so much bigger than where we're
at now we're just at the very beginning
i realized jack you got to stop me
anytime i talk about taxes
uh we started recently it's called the
millennial money channel it's me andre
kevin and jeremy and we had a live
stream going and i think we had like 8
000 people on and the second i've
mentioned taxes
300 people left that minute wow i
realized nobody likes talking about
taxes
it's not it's not a fun topic it brings
people down then they're like ah crap my
tax season so
sorry guys no more taxes final question
how much money do you make
every month from blockfy interest
uh we actually it's funny you say that i
i don't do a lot of staking off interest
we're actually getting
into doing more of that celsius block
five crypto.com those are all companies
that that we use
but for me over the last well you got to
see
you see when we're talking about where
we came from last year to where we're at
here
um and so for us in that process it was
more valuable for us to be liquid just
over the last four months
we've actually had certain point like
certain amounts of crypto that we said
we want to set
this aside we want to set you know a
million card on osi we once had a
thousand ethereum aside we want to set a
hundred bitcoin aside
um and so once we've now done that and
we've got certain amounts of crypto that
we're happy with what we have
now we're actually looking at moving it
over to those other platforms i
i'm just the guy i like to move i'm a
fast mover i'm not patient you know
like to me and you know you see this
year
eight percent yeah that's pretty good i
guess i'll take eight percent you know
i'm happy with eight percent i know i
like doing like seventeen hundred
percent you know that's kind of my
special hundred percent
yes that's good yeah so that's okay yeah
we
we swing for the fences around here we
we don't play small ball what's the
biggest amount that you've lost
the biggest amount that i've lost in one
trade i've lost two hundred thousand
dollars before on one trade
yeah i mean it's it's it's fun stuff
though i mean it's fun when you can
to me it's a lot like video game money
you know like you play grand theft auto
or
or whatever the case may be and like you
look at the numbers adding up and they
don't even seem real
like that's kind of the point that we've
gotten to like it's it it's very
ridiculous
uh so we just take it all in stride and
and one thing people will know about me
is people that know me for sure and
people that watch my channel is i'm the
same guy you know i'm the same guy no
matter if i was
you know barely having enough money to
pay my bills or whether i got enough
money to buy a yacht like
it don't matter i'm gonna be the same
guy and so um you know
i know sometimes like we we recently
brought on uh a videographer
uh we have a channel uh hit network
maybe i mentioned it earlier where we
show behind the scenes stuff what we do
we brought on mike he's actually back
here behind behind my shoulder
and uh you know mike listens to the
numbers we talk about
like just casually and he's like what
like
what is this you know and right it's
just new generation of money you know
that's what we're leading and and people
come in and we're kind of numb to it in
a sense that
we're thankful we're very thankful and
very grateful for our audience
we're very thankful and grateful for the
for the fact that i stuck through
cryptocurrency through bear market
stacking up crypto when it wasn't
popular to do so
continue to believe in the message we're
very thankful and grateful for all that
we really believe this is just the
beginning you know we really believe
this is just the beginning for
everything that we're gonna do um and so
you know the numbers are crazy and we're
very
you know aware of that but we're
grounded we're the same people we treat
everybody
you know we respect and treat everybody
nice and i think that's what you know
you don't see that all the time with
with people that get to come up so cool
i like it
anything else no thank you so much for
coming on it was amazing meeting you
yeah those numbers were crazy and that
was a great conversation
yeah definitely thanks for for coming on
and uh thank you to the bit squad for
making this possible you know going in
and talking to graham and him being
gracious enough to have us on it's been
a real fun time
thank you guys so much really appreciate
it guys if you've watched it all the way
through make sure to subscribe
hit the notification bell hit the like
button links down below in the
description
thank you so much for watching and until
next time
do that right there that's what i was
writing that's your camera okay
it's my camera it's me and your camera
you